now there are just a few days to go
before an election that could determine
the destiny of the whole of Europe if
the polls are to be believed German
Chancellor Angela Merkel is assured of a
fourth term the results will be watched
almost as closely in Athens as they are
in Berlin mrs merkel's hard stance on
dealing with the Greek debt crisis has
been multiple bailouts and years of
austerity well I'm joined now by Dimitri
papademetriou who is Greece's economy
minister so good evening to sir mrs.
Merkel has made life very difficult for
the average Greek citizen over the last
few years and her government
how would Athens welcome another term of
her well it's not appropriate for me to
say whether this is going to be good or
bad I think that mrs. Merkel has been
very helpful in some cases and I think
she will continue to be a friend and a
member of the eurozone and the Greek
government will work with her if she's a
new chancellor you still regard Germany
as a friend even after all they've put
the Greeks through everything I think I
think that you know we are in the
eurozone and Germany has helped Greece
in one way there have been difficult
times clearly but I think that we are in
for the betterment of Europe and
eurozone there's some difference of
opinion clearly about the difficulties
that the Greek people have gone and
these are actually serious difficulties
but on the other hand as we have seen of
late there is an interest that we solve
the Greek crisis and I think we are on
the road to recovery the market
certainly seems to agree with you I mean
the market is putting in a lower
probability of a Greek default than it
has at any time in the last three years
I mean can you difference if we say a
corner has been turned for Greece
absolutely I can say that I think if you
look at any of the economic variables
you see they all in an upward trend
growth has come into grace for two
quarters that we have seen and all
indications is that Greece is going to
have a real growth rate of around 2% its
1.8 that's been suggested there in the
forecast but we think that we will
we are 2% and probably most likely 3%
next year
now the currents 86 billion euro bailout
expires August next year are you
confident that you'll have met all of
the conditions that were attached to
that by then as you know we're going
through a third review process we are
very confident by November you're a
group meeting we will have completed if
not all most of them and therefore I
think we will not have a difficulty that
we had in the previous review which took
much longer than it should have
and yet the European Central Bank's she
country chief in Greece has worn down
his recently is this weekend that he's
worried about potential backtracking
well I think that the governor of Greece
has his own view but I think we have
shown that we can deliver what we have
agreed and this is what we commune to do
we're very consistent in delivering
exactly what who have a great you
mentioned the recent growth rights to
consecutive quarters as growth as you
say when when does that stop feeding
through into markedly lower unemployment
rates I mean the the jobless rate is
still 21% but you have to look at what
happened since the 2016 and 2015 and I
think that the unemployment rate has
come down more than five and a half
percent it's slow coming down but it is
coming down and the government is
actually concentrate you know particular
active labor market policies to have a
much bigger effect in the unemployment
rate but growth in employment it's very
important and I think that shows that
Greece has turned the corner he's on the
girls fast and it shows its vibrancy in
July you raise three billion on bond
markets I mean that was Greece's first
bond raising for quite some years are
there gonna be others in the in the
coming months well it's not clear when
it's going to happen so that there will
be some debt management but certainly
next year the we will be back into
markets
because it would be the end of the
memorandum of understanding which would
then have to be able to finance our own
bonds Demetria we got to leave it there
I'm afraid thank you very much for
joining me
with you yes very much